Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Io non c'ero una volta, io ci sono adesso.
E la mia non è una favola,
è uno spettacolo di vita.
Amo l'arte perché mi consente
di comunicare direttamente,
sotto il filo della coscienza,
di accedere al linguaggio
della pelle d'oca, della pancia,
delle strette allo stomaco,
delle lacrime e del sorriso.
Quel linguaggio è come
un abbraccio universale.
Non importa
se hai le braccia, o non le hai;
se sei lunghissimo,
o alto un metro e un tappo;
se sei bianco, nero, giallo o verde;
se ci vedi o sei cieco,
e se hai gli occhiali spessi così;
se sei fragile o una roccia;
se sei biondo, hai i capelli viola
o il naso storto;
se sei immobilizzato a terra
o guardi il mondo dalle profondità
più inesplorate del cielo.
Un abbraccio di quelli veri,
non bisogna barare,
è un abbraccio e nient'altro.
La tua arte parla per te,
al di là di tutto,
racconterà chi sei,
indipendentemente da quello
che gli altri vedono,
che gli altri vogliono vedere.
La vista è un senso sopravvalutato,
e se lo dico io, che sono
una ballerina e una pittrice,
potete credermi.
Io non c'ero una volta,
però un inizio ci vuole ed è questo.
(Applausi)
Questo è il prologo,
l'inizio del mio libro,
in cui racconto la mia esperienza di vita
e si intitola:
"Cosa ti manca per essere felice?"
Una domanda un po'
provocatoria, un po' tosta,
con cui ho voluto e desidero
invitare le persone
non solo a leggere il mio libro,
ma anche, così,
a condividere e ad accostarsi
a quella che è la mia esperienza di vita.
Ho voluto iniziare
con un video che è di danza:
io sono una ballerina,
e l'arte a volte parla davvero per te.
Non ci sarebbe bisogno di parole,
di aggiungere altro
alla danza, alla pittura, alla musica.
Però mi sono accorta, nel corso
della mia esperienza di vita,
che le persone poi avevano anche bisogno
di capire come una bambina prima,
una ragazza, una donna
che è nata senza le braccia
abbia scelto di diventare una ballerina,
di danzare, di dipingere
e di fare quello
che la vita mi sta donando.
E allora ho capito che, in realtà,
dovevo usare anche la mia voce
per condividere con gli altri
quello che ho avuto in dono,
ma che non solo ho avuto,
ma ho anche scelto e deciso,
insieme alla mia splendida famiglia
di trasformarlo in vita vera.
Così, in realtà io,
seduta dietro questo tavolo
mi sento un po' come una professoressa
che è venuta qui a insegnarvi qualcosa,
ma vi assicuro che non è
assolutamente così;
anzi, io credo che la vita
non si possa insegnare,
ma la vita ognuno di noi la deve vivere,
però si può condividere con gli altri;
ed è una delle cose più grandi e più belle
che la vita mi stia donando,
ma non posso condividere
la mia esperienza con voi
se non mi metto a mio agio
e vi assicuro che così
non sono tanto a mio agio,
anche se sono bella comoda.
Faccio qualcosa che in realtà
una signora non dovrebbe fare,
ma io sono venuta qui proprio per voi.
Intanto salgo sul tavolo
così vi vedo meglio
è una cosa che non posso non fare
per essere me stessa è quella di -
son carine le mia scarpe, vero?
Vernice... son carine,
però così mi sento intrappolata,
mi sento legata
perché i miei piedi,
che voi avete visto danzare,
che mi portano in giro,
in realtà per me
sono soprattutto le mie mani.
Quindi vi presento le mie mani
e ora mi sento più libera
per raccontarmi a voi
in maniera reale, vera, sincera.
E come mi disse una volta
una bambina di dieci anni,
"Simona non è vero che tu non hai le mani,
hai le mani in basso".
E io l'ho trovata la definizione più bella
che qualcuno potesse darmi
e non mi stupisco che sia stata
una bambina a darmela,
perché lei in realtà ha visto
quella che è l'utilità:
io non avendo le braccia,
non avendo le mani -
le mie mani ci sono,
sono solo spostate un po' più in basso.
Potenzialmente, quello che ho fatto io,
cioè riuscire ad usare
i miei piedi come mani,
potenzialmente lo avreste
potuto fare tutti voi,
solo che siete nati
con le mani un po' più in su
e quindi non avete avuto la necessità
di trasformare i vostri piedi in mani;
e a volte in realtà, vi confesso,
un po' mi dispiace per i vostri piedi
vederli sempre dentro con le scarpe.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Un'altra bambina, questo ultimamente,
dopo che io per un po' di tempo -
io, come vedete, sono vera italiana,
perché gesticolo -
e questa bambina mi disse:
"Ma poi come fai a camminare?"
Perché lei le aveva viste
[come] mani, non più piedi,
avevano smesso di essere piedi.
Questo, mi rendo conto,
che agli occhi degli altri
può essere qualcosa di straordinario,
perché è una cosa
che non è così comune fare,
però vi assicuro che per me
è la mia ordinarietà.
Arrivare a questa ordinarietà
è stato non voglio dire facile,
perché io credo che tutti noi
sappiamo molto bene
che nella vita di facile
non ci sia assolutamente nulla
e spesso dalle cose più difficili
riusciamo a trarre, a tirare fuori
il meglio di noi.
È un po' anche questa domanda:
cosa ti manca per essere felice?
Noi pensiamo che per
essere felici ci serva tutto,
e pensiamo sempre alla felicità
come al raggiungimento
di un traguardo, di un percorso:
arriviamo e la laurea,
piuttosto che qualsiasi
altro target della nostra vita,
possa essere la fine,
il momento in cui siamo felici.
Io ho scoperto che invece per me
la felicità è il viaggio,
riuscire a scoprire che ogni giorno,
anche in quello più difficile
della nostra vita,
noi possiamo comunque avere un momento
in cui, diciamo, ci rubiamo,
ci prendiamo per noi un po' di felicità.
Questo l'ho imparato
nel corso della mia vita
grazie a dei genitori straordinari,
grazie a una famiglia che mi ha accolta
come un grande dono
e questo per me è stato
l'inizio più bello, più importante
che io potessi avere;
e poi insieme ci siamo costruiti
la nostra vita, abbiamo imparato.
La mia mamma diceva sempre
che lei è cresciuta con me,
capendo che le mani
erano un po' più in basso,
capendo che alcune cose
dovevano essere messe nella casa
in un altro posto,
ma quella diventava la nostra normalità,
era la nostra prospettiva
nei confronti della nostra vita.
E io penso sempre che,
con la nostra semplicità e normalità,
se lo abbiamo fatto noi,
che forse siamo partiti, così,
da un punto di partenza
non uguale a quello degli altri,
non voglio dire più difficile, inferiore,
semplicemente diverso
da quello degli altri,
lo possiamo fare tutti noi.
E non ci possono essere scuse
che ci impediscano, di dire
"No, noi non lo possiamo fare".
Questa è la cosa per me più importante
da condividere con gli altri.
Io sono felice di avervi mostrato
questo video di questa danza,
perché non è un video a caso.
Sono tanti anni che danzo,
che danzo in teatri importanti
e di video ne avevo davvero tantissimi,
tra l'altro lì ballo con un ballerino
del teatro alla Scala di Milano,
Marco Messina,
ma quello era un balletto speciale,
perché quel giorno,
l'anno scorso, nel 2012,
la mia mamma quel giorno veniva operata
e io avrei voluto stare accanto a lei,
ma lei me lo ha impedito,
perché dovevo andare a danzare
in questo evento
e lei mi disse: "Tu devi andare a fare
quello per cui noi abbiamo lottato tanto,
e questa danza ci porterà fortuna".
Era un concerto per il Papa,
è andato su Rai1
e io vi assicuro che sono partita
quel giorno, col treno,
potete immaginare
con che cosa dentro il cuore,
ma sapevo che lei aveva ragione,
perché lei ha sempre avuto ragione,
ha sempre saputo,
da quando mi ha tenuto
la prima volta tra le braccia,
che la nostra vita sarebbe stata speciale,
più impegnativa forse, ma intensa;
e quindi non dovevamo lasciare
che nulla ci impedisse di fare
quello che dovevamo fare.
Così ho danzato per lei;
e ogni volta che lo ridanzo,
ogni volta che lo propongo
attraverso di un video,
lei la vedo che mi sorride,
perché sei mesi dopo è salita in cielo,
la vigilia di Natale.
Quindi ora ho capito
l'importanza di quel video
e l'importanza che continua
ad avere nella mia vita
e nella vita delle persone che incontro
e questo è un dono,
questo è qualcosa di grande,
perché anche attraverso il dolore
possiamo comprendere delle cose
che ci aiutano a dare un senso più grande
a quello che in quel momento
pensiamo che stiamo perdendo,
che non abbiamo più, che ci fa male.
Allora io racconto la mia felicità,
ma la racconto anche attraverso
le difficoltà, il dolore, la perdita;
ma con un linguaggio che mi permette, però
di far trasparire, sotto, l'amore,
la voglia di vivere
e questo grande dono che è la vita.
Un grande Papa, Giovanni Paolo II, diceva:
"Prendete la vita nelle vostre mani
e fatene un capolavoro".
Al di là che l'abbia detto un Papa,
io credo che sia una frase per tutti noi,
perché la vita ce l'abbiamo tutti noi,
perché è il nostro capolavoro
e ogni giorno noi possiamo scegliere
di mettere una pennellata in più,
un tratto, di cancellare qualcosa a volte,
possiamo fare anche quello.
Però di renderlo nostro, vivo,
che ci permetta di arrivare, anche,
alla fine della giornata con un sorriso
e di risvegliarci con un sorriso.
Questa è la mia filosofia di vita,
questo è il modo in cui,
ogni giorno, scelgo di vivere;
ed è bello condividerlo con gli altri,
attraverso la danza,
attraverso la pittura,
attraverso il mio libro
e attraverso i miei incontri,
attraverso quello
che ho avuto in più, forse,
o che ho avuto esattamente
come tutti gli altri.
Ma l'ho voluto, l'ho preso
e continuo a volerlo e a tenerlo con me,
che è la mia vita.
Io vi lascio con questa frase:
cosa ti manca per essere felice,
ma non perché ve la faccio io la domanda,
ma perché forse tutti noi, ogni giorno,
dovremmo svegliarci con un qualcosa
che ci dia anche lo stimolo,
verso noi stessi,
di non sentire sempre
che tutto è così pesante,
ma di cercare anche
in un giorno qualunque,
di pioggia, dove tutto va male,
un piccolo sorriso
e un piccolo briciolo di felicità,
che non è quella alta, quella grande,
quella che io chiamo, quando dico
che sono spudoratamente felice,
lo dico perché è un po' una sfida,
a provare a far sì che ogni giorno
un po' di quella felicità
che ho accumulato
diventi una cascata di gioia, di amore.
Concludo con la fine
del mio libro, che dice:
"Non è retorica. La vita è una danza.
Il coreografo mi ha fatto entrare in scena
in maniera rocambolesca.
Il resto del cast non lo sapeva
e si sono un po' spaventati lì per lì,
poi mi hanno fatto spazio
e sono diventata una ballerina anche io.
Come tutti, ho i miei punti forti
e i miei punti deboli,
e a furia di danzare
ho scoperto perfettamente quali sono.
Sono come Sansone, ho la forza nei capelli
e come mio nonno ho la forza nel sorriso.
Sono come un calabrone,
volo anche se non ho le ali;
e come Anna mi metto le scarpette rosa
alla faccia dei busti ortopedici.
Vado in altalena,
mi scapicollo ad istinto, come mia madre
e poi ho bisogno di silenzio,
come mio padre.
Sono felice, smodatamente,
spudoratamente felice
ed è una gioia raccontarla,
questa mia felicità.
Il mio punto debole è che dopo aver
ballato tanto, dipinto e parlato,
mi sento fragile, come svuotata,
mi sento esposta;
e anche se non vorrei mai
scendere dal palco,
non vorrei mai finire una tela,
non vorrei mai smettere di chiacchierare:
[ma] devo farlo,
altrimenti potrei disperdermi
negli occhi altrui
e non sarei più io, Simona.
Quando viene quel momento mi inchino,
mi inchino profondamente a ringraziare
quanti mi hanno dedicato tempo e cuore.
Sento i capelli scivolare
lungo la schiena, ed arrivare a terra,
e il respiro farsi più regolare,
e vedo i miei piedi.
Allora comincio ad immaginare
un nuovo sogno.
(Applausi)
Rimetto le scarpe.
Grazie.
(Applausi)